dépositaires de l'autorité de l'état
dans le département le préfet le
représentant direct du gouvernement nous
sommes en ligne avec jean jacques brot
le préfet des yvelines bonjour monsieur
le préfet bonjour monsieur
nous allons voir comment vous avez
supervisé la situation ces dernières
semaines rappelé également les mesures
en cours et puis forcément évoqué les
premiers éléments les prémices encore
concernant le déconfinement en attendant
c'est bien le confinement qui est
d'actualité
cela fait six semaines les beaux jours
sont bien installés n'est pas question
de penser à se relâcher c'est le message
que vous allez passer encore envers la
veille de ce week end pardon oui bien
sûr nous sommes toujours en arêtes
enfants en confinement comme l'ont
rappelé les membres du gouvernement et
les autorités scientifiques et y compris
les bien entendu les hospitaliers les
médecins yvelinois nous sommes en
confinement
les premiers résultats arrivent
incontestablement puisque les hôpitaux
des yvelines sont mois surchargés les
ligues à quelques lits de réanimation
libre donc ça veut bien exprimé que le
confinement par rapport à cette pandémie
épouvantable produit des résultats
mais il ne faut pas se relâcher il faut
accepter avec autant de bonne volonté en
tout cas de discipline nécessaire pour
chacun d'entre nous les rênes de ce
confinement qui peuvent être
effectivement très contraignant pour
certains d'entre nous la communauté
musulmane débute le ramadan ce vendredi
c'est normalement au moment des sens de
partage
et tout cela en commun les différents
représentants du culte ont appelé à leur
fidèle à s'adapter cette année à
respecter aussi une fermeture des
mosquées
vous allez y veiller avec les services
de la préfecture oui mais d'abord nous y
avons travaillé en amont précisément
avec le conseil des institutions
musulmanes des yvelines qui a produit il
ya une semaine maintenant une semaine
avant le début du ramadan
aujourd'hui un communiqué très important
qui appelait précisément à
une discipline incivisme spéciaux
compatible avec le bon exercice du mois
du ramadan les autorités compétentes
musulmane ont exprimé à quel point à
l'instar d'autres fidèles d'autres
religions yvelinois comme les juifs les
chrétiens récemment pour les fêtes de
pessah et de pâques l'ont montré eh bien
les musulmans selon eux entendaient
aussi pratiquer leur religion y compris
le jeûne la prière
la charité est certaine forme de prière
dans le confinement et non pas avec les
formes extérieures qui peuvent être
habituels qui sont ailleurs puce culture
culturel cultuel de cette fois ci en
appelant à ne pas s'y adonner donc je
remercie beaucoup naturellement le
conseil d'administration du simi est
d'avoir appelé les fidèles à cette
retenue
nous entendons être pédagogue comme eux
mais naturellement nous empêcherons par
exemple si ça arrivait des personnes
produisant des petits gâteaux ou des
plats etc
nous leur interdirons de les vendre
comme ça à la sauvette puisque les
marchés sont interdits et des très rares
exceptions près on ne peut pas envisager
d'exception donc voilà pour une partie
de la population c'est un mois de
ramadhan spéciale qui s'annonce de même
qu'il a été très spéciale singulier et
contraignant pour les protestants pour
les catholiques pour les juifs pour les
orthodoxes tout à fait récemment pour
pâques
vous l'avez évoqué aussi dans votre
réponse la question des marchés peut
être revenir aussi parce que vous
recevez toujours encore des demandes de
certains qui s'interroge pourquoi tel
marché pourquoi pas un autre aujourd'hui
quelle est la règle qui s'applique
voilà alors en effet au départ il faut
revenir aux origines le confinement
s'est accompagnée d'une demande
gouvernementale du premier ministre et
de tous les ministres donc extrêmement
clair de fermeture de tous les marchés
c'est la règle
la dérogation a pu être envisagé
pour ma part je les comprise de façon
suivante c'est-à-dire en autorisant au
bout de quelques semaines je le
reconnais des marchés l'euro à rouvrir
là où il n'y a pas de possibilités
d'approvisionnement alternatifs jeu chez
nous avons permis mes collaborateurs et
moi après étude très particulière dans
certains cas je pense aux halles de
versailles une forme de réouverture mais
extrêmement organisés limites et
contingenté avec une organisation
particulière un sens pour les personnes
qui viennent et pas de contacts entre
les produits et les personnes et
naturellement les règles les gestes
barrières devant être réglée à ceux qui
continuent à insister parfois très
lourdement je pense à tel ou tel élu je
réexplique qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
contrainte pour le plaisir et qu'il
s'agit bien entendu pas de d'une volonté
de réprimer ou de contraindre telle ou
telle organisation maraîchères et
horticoles
il s'agit simplement avec autant dé
quitter que possible de respecter une
consigne gouvernementale
je répète d'ailleurs sur ce point et ça
nous fait un lien avec la question du
ramadan que si dans tel ou tel marché
urbain
demain on nous proposait à mes services
et à moi d organisation très réglementé
qui permettent la vente de certains
aliments particulièrement prisé par les
fidèles musulmans pendant le mois de
ramadan si les gestes barrières étaient
bien respectées si la police municipale
et les placiers le vérifier s'il y avait
peut-être certains paquet tout préparé à
l'avancé
eh bien pourquoi ne pas organiser des
choses dans des halles ou dans des
marchés je reste vert mais il faut des
choses
extraits des organisations très précise
et très original il s'agit pas en milieu
urbain découvrir tout simplement je
restais sur cette question du
confinement est ce qu'il est il est
respecté globalement aujourd'hui et pour
étendre un petit peu ma question on le
voit dans certains quartiers c'est assez
compliqué il ya eu alors c'est pas
uniquement liée au confinement mais des
tensions dans certains quartiers avec
les forces de l'ordre qui ont dû
intervenir c'est aussi des choses qui
peuvent interpeller les citoyens les
concitoyens de juillet on est en période
de confinement et on voit ces scènes de
violence avec dans certains quartiers
des affrontements avec la police
précisément je crois monsieur que ce
parce que le confinement est plutôt bien
respectée dans des marques divine qu'il
gêne certaines occupations
certains trafics certaines ventes et
certaines habitudes et donc si on ajoute
cette gêne et je pense particulièrement
à ce qui s'est déjà produit à changer où
il ya quelques mois et ce qui s'y est
produit à nouveau très récemment
si on ajoute cette entrave par le
confinement d'un certain nombre
d'activités illicites et et au noir il
faut bien dire les choses plus la
fatigue qui naît de du temps qui
s'écoule vous avez dit on n'entre qu'en
même temps la sixième semaine de
confinement ça a expliqué des prises à
partie de la police assez récurrente il
y en a eu plusieurs soirs de suite oui
dans plusieurs quartiers des yvelines
c'est vrai néanmois nous avons eu la
chance pour l'instant de ne pas aller
aux extrêmes
ce sont des formes de violences urbaines
incontestable qu'ils sont grâce aux 10
heures du mans dont font preuve les
forces de police restée relativement
dans un cadre relativement je ne l'aï
pas dire acceptable mais ils sont par
contre continue peut-être les forces
depuis cet adjectif relativement encore
une fois parce qu'il a hâte de voir que
on s'en prend la police et parfois aux
biens et aux personnes en balançant des
mortiers en balançant des pierres et
autres objets c'est pas convenable c'est
pas supportable et d'ailleurs la
procureure de la république est on est
très régulièrement informés et mène la
politique pénale qui est la sienne et
qui est je crois apprécier tous depuis
plusieurs mois donc sachez bien que les
services de police et de gendarmerie
surtout à l'occasion de ce mois de
ramadan qui peut dans certains cas comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure
impliqué quelques mouvements
complémentaire de population est en tout
cas être pris comme prétexte par des
malfaisants pour leur entreprise
je répète que les forces de police et de
gendarmerie sont particulièrement
attentives vigilante seront à la fois
pédagogue mais ferme et que en tout cas
mes collaborateurs et moi même ainsi que
les polices municipale et nationale la
gendarmerie
les maires et nous nous sommes vraiment
sur le qui vive
là on n'est pas encore rodé confinement
on l'a bien compris mais néanmoins il ya
des discussions qui s'engage entre les
différents élus notamment qui sont
sollicités par le gouvernement j'imagine
que vous aussi vous êtes sollicité vous
serez mis à contribution
d'autant que la consigne pour l'instant
ce serait un déconfinement global mais
avec et des discussions sur un plan
territorial avec un 10 nommés préfets
préfets et élus des maires des
communautés des différentes communes
alors effectivement je pense que
l'occasion de cette crise très intense
rappelle un certain nombre d'autorités
ou d'observateurs que à la base quand il
s'agit de sécurité civile s'est en effet
le dialogue qui s'instaure entre le
préfet et chacun des maires qui la clé
de des secours apportés aux populations
y compris dans le dans la durée nous
avons la chance voyez-vous dans les
yvelines d'avoir un climat de confiance
que je qualifierais de très exceptionnel
entre les autorités préfectorales le
conseil départemental le conseil
régional les mains
les intercommunalités mais c'est surtout
les mères dix ans essentiellement les
maires qui sont concernés avec le
soutien du conseil départemental et
aussi du conseil régional et des
parlementaires il y a une qualité de
dialogue entre ses pouvoirs publics se
tient le dire à nouveau publiquement qui
fait que en particulier jusqu'à
maintenant dans nos périodes où il faut
bien le dire
il a fallu parfois aider le système
hospitalier
le conforter conforter les ehpad martel
masque telle organisation renfort
administratifs etc etc
il faut que les yvelinois grâce à vous
monsieur comprenne qu'il y a eu un
dialogue permanent de proximité de
terrain
une explication constant donc nous
n'allons pas re découvrir ce que
semblent parfois redécouvrir les
observateurs plus nationaux c'est à dire
la nécessité de fonder l'action publique
sur une connaissance de terrain
une connaissance des personnes de
proximité je veux aussi mentionné les
associations caritatives les
associations qui représente les
entreprises les chefs d'entreprises eux
mêmes dans cette ce moment où on
envisage le déconfinement nous sommes en
lien quotidien
que fait l'état par exemple je suis
beaucoup de dialogues par téléphone par
mail par texto par visioconférence par
audio-conférence non pas entre nous ça
n'aurait aucun sens mais les uns avec
les autres je veux dire avec les maires
avec le conseil départemental avec le
système hospitalier au cas par cas pour
organiser et en partie parfois avec le
système d pour compenser ce qui n'est
pas toujours être donné donc nous sommes
de ce point de vue extrêmement motivés
ensemble pour en fonction des mots
d'ordre qui seront données quelle date
et y aura-t-il des volontaires pour les
écoles ou pas il subit chaque masque ou
pas etc
je prends l'exemple des tests
actuellement engagés pour voir si dans
les ehpad
certaines personnes ne sont pas tatin ne
sont pas attendus
rulhe c'est bien ça s'est fait par une
mobilisation que je salue de la rs 78
est tout à fait remarquable avec le
conseil départemental le système
hospitalier en général et le soutien de
l'action de l'état d'envoyer pour chaque
problème
nous avons réussi une si une nuit en
conjugaison de nos personnalités et des
pouvoirs et des personnes qui sont
concernées sur la façon dont va
s'articuler le déconfinement pour pour
conclure les choses seront plus précises
on précisé à quel moment à quel moment
vous serez en mesure d'annoncer dans les
yvelines les choses se passeront telle
manière réputé cette question est
extrêmement comment dire pour être
rester politiquement correct est
acceptable c'est très compliqué de
deviner les choses on voit en tout cas
il ya une chose qui paraît de plus en
plus clair c'est que les autorités
gouvernementales comprennent qu'il faut
revenir aux méthodes d'antan c'est à
dire comme je viens de le décrire une
qualité de coopération d'anticipation et
d'action la plus des proches du terrain
possible
ça c'est une certitude capitaux c'est
une conviction que joueur que j'aie
équipe dont on voit qu'elle commence à
se propager
si j'en crois ce que je lis dans la
presse est ce que j'entends donc je ne
peux pas donner de date du tout il ya
l'horizon qui a été fixé par le
président 11 mai il y à ce qu'on dit le
premier ministre et des autres ministres
on voit qu'on tend vers cet horizon de
date
après chaque jour qui passe nous nous
préparons nous nous préparons parce que
je sais que certaines grandes
collectivités le conseil régional mais
en ce moment le conseil départemental où
certaines méric commandé des masques
nous allons coordonner pour éviter les
doublons je sais que certaines
associations caritatives ont besoin d'
aide alimentaire parce qu'il ya des
désarrois encore accru nous nous
concertons là aussi voyez c'est plus une
méthode s'applique dès maintenant la
date
dès qu'on saura vous le diront mais ça
n'a pas ça ne sera pas comme le coup de
départ d'une course à pied ce sera
peut-être un peu plus original
merci beaucoup monsieur le préfet
d'avoir été en ligne en connexion avec
nous pour faire un point sur la
situation aujourd'hui après cette
sixième semaine de de confinement merci
à vous merci merci ma chemise